I grew up in rural parts of Kenya which
have quite high rates of of poverty you
know family we used to get on our
bicycles each of us carrying three jerry
cans will be like three or four people
me my uncles and my cousins will travel
like 20 kilometers on a bicycle for that
day to go look for water over four out
of five people in the world that don't
have access to safe drinking water to
live in rural areas this situations
particularly compounded in Africa where
hand pumps and rural water supplies
often fail and one of the newest
technologies that's now emerge in terms
of mobile solutions and cloud-based
computing is allowing us to advance with
innovative ways to address this problem
the reach program is aiming to make five
million poor people water secure in
Africa and Asia groundwater is one of
the safest supplies of water in rural
regions of Kenya so being able to track
the depth of the aquifer is critically
important in a be able to understand how
healthy that water system is we may be
familiar with the idea of using one
smartphone or smart devices to carry
around with us and to use to monitor our
own health and the idea here was well
can't we put some of those mobile health
devices into the handle of a pump so the
data is really interesting when you see
a war accelerometry ports you kind of
get you get these curves of the actual
motion of someone pumping when the pump
is deeper the the weight of the water
that you're lifting is much larger and
so there'll be more vibrations whereas
when the pump is shallower you're
lifting less water and so there will be
smaller vibration
imagine you have multiple intelligent
nodes they're all transmitting data you
have to integrate data in a cloud-based
system from data nodes across an entire
region tens of thousands of pumps in our
case that needs to be done in a
cloud-based situation where one has a
huge amount of computing resource to be
able to perform their heavy weight
machine learning algorithms on the
integrated data we like the inclusion of
the Azure machine learning framework
which allowed us to port our existing R
and python based machine learning tools
directly into a safe cloud-based system
as ml makes fitting machine learning
models much faster as I can explore the
parameter space much quicker on the
clouds than just on my own computer I
think making data usable and effective
decision-makers absolutely critical
policymakers and decision makers have
the responsibility to take very
difficult and onerous decisions and
there's there's a huge information
deficit in terms of how they should
proceed so the ability to collect data
at scale in a way that's usable and
appropriate for them is extremely
powerful initially it used to take more
than 30 days to repair a hand pump but
now because we have this information
when a hand pump it's down we can repair
them within less than three days or
sometimes even 48 hours so that has
enabled the villages to have better
access to water my hope and aspirations
is to see this system making my village
and other villages back in Kenya water
secure and moving them out of poverty